they made real progress that's the
report from Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo following hours of meetings this
morning and last night with North Korean
vice chairman kim yeongcheol it could be
nothing short of tragic to let this
opportunity go to waste the North Korean
government spent decades building a
nuclear weapons program to safeguard its
regime secretary Pompeo says his mission
is to convince kim jeong-hoon that his
nuclear weapons actually present a
threat to his security not protection
since President Trump agreed to a summit
with Kim jong-un the rhetoric between
the countries has vacillated between
threatening and complementary one not
ought to be either surprised or
frightened or deterred by moments where
it looks like there are challenges and
difficulties things that can't be
bridged our mission is to bridge them
one week after president Trump released
a letter to Kim jong-un canceling the
June 12th summit in Singapore
Kim's top emissary on this issue is in
the United States carrying a letter for
president Trump Pompeyo says kim
yeongcheol will deliver it tomorrow in
washington North Korea claims it
destroyed its punggye-ri nuclear test
site to demonstrate what it says is a
willingness to dismantle its program now
the Middlebury Institute for
International Studies says satellite
images show North Korea removing
materials from the site before its
destruction the Institute confirms to
Fox News that quote the North Koreans
are still treating information about
their nuclear weapons program as
sensitive that suggests North Korea is
unlikely to hand over actual nuclear
weapons and while his vice-chairman is
in the united states kim jeong-hoon
hosted Russian Foreign Minister Sergey
Lavrov who delivered a greeting from
President Vladimir Putin he sends his
warmest regards and best wishes and the
big endeavors that have been initiated
on the Korean Peninsula with your
participation as the Russian government
tries to involve itself in this issue
Lavrov also invited Kim to Moscow
the original date for this summit is
less than two weeks away June 12th when
asked whether it's actually going to
happen on that date Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo would only say he doesn't
know Brett Richardson live the State
Department rich thanks